from the way that olympic gymnast simone
biles
is being praised this week you might
think that the decorated superstar put
on a heroic
display during the team competition in
tokyo uh
yesterday and led her squad to a gold
medal
many prominent politicians like ayanna
pressley and corey bush and many others
have
made public statements applauding her
the white house press secretary
expressed
gratitude and support said we all should
express gratitude and support
for simone biles deadspin gushed over
the
what they call the most impressive move
of her career
former olympians joined in the group hug
many athletes came out to support her
articles have been written extolling her
bravery
declaring that her achievements this
week have sent a quote powerful message
to the world cnn called her performance
impactful
the new yorker described her quote
radical courage
the new york times talked about her
champion mindset
she's been hailed for her strength and
for setting an amazing example
being a great athlete a great role model
all based on
what she did yesterday women's advocacy
groups have come to her
defense have thanked her for all that
she's done
it has been perhaps the most effusive
praise that has ever been heaped on a
quitter
and that's what simone biles did to earn
this exuberant applause after all she
gave up
after struggling in the qualifying
rounds and botching the first event
in the women's team finals biles decided
to withdraw from the meat
the best gymnast on the squad the leader
one of the most celebrated u.s
olympic athletes of all time chose to
abandon her team in the middle of the
finals
her teammates would finish second behind
russia while biles went on to receive
even more acclaim than a gold medal
would have earned her probably
there was some talk early on suggesting
that biles had been physically injured
but that was not the case
biles has since explained that she left
the competition in order to focus on her
mental health and her quote mindfulness
she complained that the olympics
haven't been fun this year she said
quote this olympic games i wanted to i
wanted it to be for myself when i came
in and i felt like i was still doing it
for other people returning to this theme
later she said that it's important to
put mental health first because if you
don't then you're not going to enjoy
your sport
she complained about the pressure that
she's been under here's a little more
from biles herself explaining
uh why she quit here she is and it's
been really stressful this olympic games
i think
just as a whole not having an audience
there are a lot of different variables
going into it it's been
a long week it's been a long olympic
process it's been a long
year um so just a lot of different
variables and i think
we're just a little bit too stressed out
but we should be out here having fun and
sometimes that's not the case
i just felt like it would be a little
bit better to take a backseat
uh work on my mindfulness and i knew
that the girls would do
an absolutely great job and i didn't
want to risk the team a medal for
kind of my screw-ups because they've
worked way too hard for that so
i just decided that those girls need to
go in and do the rest of the competition
yeah i say um put mental health first
because
if you don't then you're not going to
enjoy your sport and you're not going to
succeed as much as you want to so it's
okay sometimes to even sit out the big
competitions
to focus on yourself because it shows
how strong of a competitor and person
that you really are
now the people who wish to make excuses
for her have offered all kinds of
rationales
that biles herself has not offered there
have been lots of people online talking
about for example her sexual assault and
speculating that
somehow that might have contributed to
this but she has not once
cited that as a reason for her decision
and frankly it seems pretty disgusting
to inject that into this
uh discussion in hopes of bailing her
out when she has not brought it up
there are others saying that she was
essentially mentally incapacitated to
the point that
she physically couldn't perform the
moves but again that's not really what
she's saying
you can listen to what she's saying she
has talked more broadly about her mental
health
mentioned multiple times that she wasn't
having fun and said again
multiple times that she needed to focus
on herself
that's what she said those are her words
she explained
why she did this we don't need to
theorize about it she
told us now the question is whether
those are good reasons
they aren't now on one hand there's
nothing terribly surprising
about the reasons that she gave for
quitting people quit
things all the time and and they almost
always do it because the thing they're
quitting
is difficult and not very fun and
they're afraid of failing
this is the universal rationale of all
quitters
everywhere for all time i have quit
things myself for that reason
you have quit things for that reason
everyone has with no exceptions
in this case there's no doubt that the
difficult thing was very difficult
indeed
the pressure she experiences as a world
famous athlete on a global stage must be
quite burdensome on both an emotional
and physical level
and that's what makes quitting
understandable
the one thing that it cannot be is
admirable
now if simone biles here's the point
okay and i want everyone to try to
understand this
because a lot of people don't apparently
it's a very simple point
if simone biles had bailed on her team
as she did and apologized after the fact
um instead of saying well i need to
focus on myself and hey they can handle
it
if she had bailed her team apologized
after the fact and the public had
reacted in an appropriately sort of bum
bummed out kind of way to the news then
there wouldn't be much else to say on
the matter
it's hard to compete in the olympics
it's hard to live up to high
expectations
lots of people quit things when they're
hard again we all have at one time or
another
that's why when someone quits we
normally shake our heads and say well
that's a shame
and then we move on with our lives
nobody's suggesting
that athletes who quit ought to be tired
and feathered in the street they might
do that in china
maybe but we're not saying that for here
i'm not advocating that we we put them
in the stockades in the middle of the
town square and throw tomatoes at them
that's not the point it's enough to be
disappointed and be done with it in fact
if that's how this had played out if she
had quit everyone was disappointed she
apologized
i wouldn't be saying a word about it i
wouldn't care personally
i wouldn't be talking about it
the problem is that now we are exhorted
not simply to understand why someone
quits but to actively applaud them
for doing it what makes the simone bile
story troubling
is not that the women's gymnastics team
had to settle for a silver medal
but that our cultural powers that be
want us to celebrate
cowardice as always it's it's not enough
to merely tolerate another person's
decision
or to be compassionate towards their
struggles we are meant now to rise to
our feet
and joyously cheer what all people
through history and most people living
in the world today
would consider shameful and unfortunate
at least
it's radical courage is the the the
phrase being used to describe this
not understandable okay not um
not not something we should sympathize
with but radically
courageous to leave your team
in the lurch it's one thing to say
simone biles quit but let's have some
empathy empathy
if that was the message i would say sure
yeah sounds good
it is quite another to say simone biles
quit
isn't that so brave uh
no it's not it is
the definition of not brave
it may be human it may be relatable but
it's the opposite
of brave to be brave is to refuse to
quit precisely when most people would
that's why we admire people who
persevere because they are rare
quitters are a dime a dozen cowardice is
a no short supply in our world
and it'll become even more common now
that we've rebranded it as courage
if we will be grant if we will grant to
cowardice the rewards of courage
without any of the effort and sacrifice
it requires why bother with courage at
all
the many defenders of simone biles have
said that she's right a role model in
fact
for prioritizing her mental health above
all else
in the era of the psychological man when
there's nothing more important than the
self's opinion of itself
it is perhaps no surprise that we should
congratulate a woman
for explicitly putting herself before
her team and her country
i had to put myself first she says that
exactly explicitly
now we are celebrating athletes who do
that it used to be the exact opposite
that's not why you compete in a team
sport that's not why you
go to the olympics for your country if
you want to focus on yourself
you don't go you don't join the team
nobody is walking up to someone someone
sitting
on a park bench and saying why aren't
you in the olympics right now
you selfish bastard
no because it's not a requirement but if
you are
taking on that responsibility then
you're not supposed to put yourself
first that is the duty the
responsibility
that you have assumed for yourself
oh but mental health right
you're not allowed to say any of this no
because because the magic phrase the
magic term
the get out of jail free card mental
health has been used
that is now the shield meant to insulate
us from all criticism
oh you think you can criticize me for a
decision i made
well you can't because it helped my
mental health
the highest virtue now is the pursuit of
your own mental well-being
courage is now the avoidance
of mental anguish which is to say that
courage is now the exact opposite
of what it has always been and what it
actually is
still now today and yet still
you have to wonder how consistently the
new moral code would even be applied
would tom brady receive
such a worship full reaction if he left
in the third quarter of a playoff game
because he wasn't having fun and needed
to work on his mindfulness
can you imagine that you can't it's
unthinkable because it would never
happen never has happened
you can't imagine tom brady in the third
quarter
of a playoff game or really that this is
the super bowl
this is the this is the super bowl for
the for this sport i mean more than the
super bowl because this happens only
once every four years as opposed to
super bowl which happens every year
especially if you're tom brady and
you've been in like 10 of them but um
can you you can't imagine tom brady
third quarter super bowl
uh going to his coach and saying i gotta
sit out
what do you mean you gotta sit are you
injured no no i i i
you know i gotta get him i'm not in the
right head space right now and i gotta
work on myself
nobody would accept that sure there have
been cases
of of sulking professional athletes
leaving the field or the court a few
seconds early
because they were frustrated and sad
during a bad loss we've seen this move
from lebron james for example perhaps
the greatest
sulker in all of sports um there are
usually a few people willing to defend
this kind of behavior from male athletes
but they've never been celebrated like a
returning war hero
the way simone biles has been and naomi
asaka before her
in fact i was arguing this point with a
sports writer on twitter last night and
he in an attempt to defend biles
brought up the fact that scotty pippen a
former
chicago bulls player in the 1994 nba
playoffs
sat out the final seconds of the game
because he was mad
that he wasn't going to get the ball
see that the guy was saying to me he
what are you saying see
here's here's an example of a male
athlete quitting on his team
well yeah it is in a very different
situation
in this case he was mad that he wasn't
giving he wanted the pressure on him and
he wasn't getting it and so he was mad
and he quit but he did quit on his team
that's true
but what happened to scottie pippen
he was universally reviled for that
everyone
everywhere criticized him to this day he
is criticized
and for good reason i've never heard
anyone call him brave
or congratulate him for prioritizing his
mental health
this is a privilege reserved only for
female athletes
at present that might change though
maybe one day we'll we'll celebrate both
male and female quitters
maybe we're fast approaching a time when
the greatest athletes will be those who
manage to feel the best about themselves
while competing at that point we won't
need it to perform
you know they won't need to perform any
athletic feats at all they can just
every sport will be them sitting in a
circle
and whispering sweet nothings to
themselves
everyone wins in the end may not make
for much of a spectator sport but at
least we will know that nobody's mental
health
has been damaged i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content